[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ces deux belges
ces jobs y en a il est comme ça avec un
miroir dans la main elle est pas très
longue bien d'un des deux îles à un
miroir dans la main il sait tout ça
c'est incroyable c'est dingue là c'est
ça je m'en sortirais jamais un lancement
bêta ça m'embête mais j'ai un vrai
problème moi c'est incroyable ce qui se
passe comment
[Musique]
et l'autre élevé mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
t'as pas l'air bien mais qu'est ce qui
il fait monsieur teinte c'est dingue
cette thèse qu'il soit le type 1 type là
je suis sûr que je le connais je suis
sûr que je ne connais même pas me
souvenir qui sait j'arrive pas l'autre
effet mais montre moi j'ai dans le
miroir il prend lui rend bien sûr que tu
ne connais elle c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
il entend des bruits dans la chambre de
ses parents il descend pige à maintes de
sang ils en trouvent là la porte de la
chambre de ses bancs et et voit sa maman
qui chevauche son papa vincent va pas il
est allongé sur le dos tout nu elle est
toute nue aussi est à quai voltaire à
son papa a que les cons qui se barre
dans tous les points tours trop ferme
l'abord il remonte dans sa chambre et
lendemain matin il dit maman faut que je
te dise un truc j'ai je crois que j'ai
fait un truc pas bien c'est n'est bon a
dû que ce te fais mon petit jérôme m'a
dit j'ai entendu du bruit de votre
chambre et je suis venu regarder à sa
mère a dit oui c'est pas terrible ça
c'est vrai alors dis tiens moment qu'est
ce que tu as vu et bien dit j'ai vu tout
était tout nu un ebit sauter comme ça
sans leur ventre à papa qui était tenue
au cias a dit oui oui oui bon c'est vrai
je veux tu as bien vu tu assez grands
maintenant ma mort dpic
tu as remarqué que papa il avait un peu
un gros ventre alors qu'est ce qu'elle
fait mais man
ça lui fait mal saute sur le ventre à
papa pour essayer de le plaisir des
petits garçons mais guy maman ça
marchera jamais ton truc bague est
pourquoi je vous dis ça badie basket
tous les matins la bonne leur gonfle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
faussement